[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et au banc ce soir tout le monde est une
grande nouvelle à vous annoncer
une excellente nouvelle on a trouvé un
traitement contre le coronavirus et
ouais c'était tout bête et franchement
ils marchent du tonnerre
c'est le confinement il faut qu'on vous
dise comment qu'il faut pas sortir de
chez vous qu'il faut rester chez vous
qu'il ne faut pas aller se balader là
sur les quais de saône ou sur les quais
de paris où 900 morts par jour 100 morts
voulait qu'on attend de quoi le millier
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
1 et après vous viendrez pleurer parce
que voilà vous êtes un jeune de 30 ans
ma mère vous avait chopé le virus si
vous voulez une assistance aux sports
vous dire ah désolé on en a pas d'accord
donc s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
faites quelque chose
restez chez vous aidez-nous en restant
chez vous ces panneaux dix ans et tout
ça que vous allez nous aider nous sommes
en guerre et la nation soutiendra ses
enfants qui personnel soignant en ville
à l'hôpital se trouve en première ligne
dans un combat qui va leur demander
énergie détermination solidarité nous
serons là brutalement le coronavirus est
entré dans nos vies en mars 2020 la
guerre est déclarée
les soignants si mal considérée si mal
rémunérés depuis longtemps sont soudain
devenus des héros en blouse blanche
on les applaudit tous les soirs on fait
beaucoup de bruit mais si on faisait le
silence aussi pour les écouter après une
semaine de réflexion confinées à la
maison je contacte des infirmières les
aides soignantes les médecins une petite
équipe à travers la france
c'est eux qui décident de ce qu'ils
filment avec comme caméra leur propre
téléphone et ce film commence aucun
d'entre nous ne sait alors que cette
première vague durera jusqu'à l'été
bonjour cindy je vous ai vu sur les
réseaux sociaux
je vous propose de participer à un
projet vous pourrez vous exprimer très
librement et filmez vous même un peu
chaque jour pour raconter ce que vous
traversez moi je suis tout seul à la
maison dès le début je suis en
confinement total des dieux le premier
patient je suis occupé mon premier
patient coville même si je m'étais
protéger au maximum pour causer avec ma
famille et mes enfants je me suis mis un
compliment total c'est à dire depuis le
12 mars je suis tout seul à la maison je
vais personne je vois là et très vite ça
devient dur mentalement faut pas se
mentir
bonjour dana et merci d'avoir accepté de
nous rejoindre
j'ai bien noté que ton stage se déroule
dans un centre de rééducation et non pas
en service comme il n'empêche qu'à
prendre ton métier d'infirmière en
pleine épidémie
c'est tout de suite le grand bain
courage et à très vite j'ai travaillé
vendredi on avait des suspicions de cas
de covile 10,9
donc moi j'ai rien su de ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui et on nous a appris que la
patiente était positif est qu'on avait
une infirmière aussi qu'ils étaient
positives alors du coup on a eu des
mesures qu'ils soient installés mais en
place alors que durant les semaines
d'avant on avait raison les soignants
n'avait pas de masque il y avait juste
les patients qui portait un masque pour
se déplacer et aller en rééducation du
coup voir les kinés les kinés eux par
contre a eu droit à mettre un masque
parce que c'était considéré qu' ils
étaient ils étaient proches des patients
alors que apparemment les infirmières et
hauts-de-seine en avait pas ce privilège
et voilà l'hôpital de revenir moore
vous exerce son métier d'aide-soignante
bienvenue vanessa je sais que tu es
journées sont très chargés mais si tu
peux filmer pendant ses pauses et aussi
à la maison ce serait formidable
j'en ai c'est compliqué aujourd'hui je
suis dans un service où c'est censé être
un service propre c'est-à-dire sans 100
personnes atteintes du coronavirus et on
s'est rendu compte concrète on avait
trois personnes qui étaient contagieuses
donc un peu de stress là dessus puisque
ça fait un moment qu'on s'occupe de ces
personnes sans se protéger pour ce virus
donc c'est plein de questions plein de
stress on verra bien je suis
impressionné par la capacité qui
démontrent quotidiennement à lutter à
s'engager contre contre cette maladie
moi je ne peux pas me contenter de leur
dire chapeau il faut aussi que je fasse
en sorte qu'il soit armé dans ce groupe
à l'état n'arrête pas de nous parler ma
des masques on a des sur nous on a des
choses qui arrivent
on n'en voit pas la couleur c ou c ou
bordel sais je sais pas moi c'est ça
disparaisse et ces voix là c'est sable
ça peut ça disparaît dans les airs parce
que moi depuis le début la only de
continuer les données au compte gouttes
par kit 1
et là je remercie terriblement une de
mes voisines qui son mari travaille dans
un magasin de bricolage et en faisant
des tris ont retrouvé une vieille boîte
de masques ffp2 l ai regardé je la
montre
elle est là je sais pas si vous verrez
parce que je pense que ça va être à
l'envers mais voilà périmés puis 2012
c'est pas grave tu la prends quand même
parce que je me dis ce sera peut-être
toujours mieux que que ces ma
chirurgicaux qui me disent que même si
les passants ou crachent dessus ça sera
efficace je suis pas sûr alors pendant
une semaine tout s'est très bien passé
notre patient kovy détestable
tout avait très bien on n'avait pas
forcément d'entreves et que les
chirurgie programmée et sont annulés on
n'a que les chirurgies d'urgence les
traumato qui rentrent donc là on a une
entrée hier et on a une détresse
détresse respiratoire ce matin donc du
coup suspicion de kovy idée que ces
urgences on a appelé le samu
donc nous étions tous un petit peu
paniqué voilà on pensait que tout allait
très bien se passer
je pensais la première qu'on allait
entre guillemets échapper et c'est vrai
qu'on commence à voir quelques urgence
depuis le début de cette épidémie
le premier soignant est tombée il ya
quelques jours à compiègne trois
soignants ont perdu la vie dans la
région grand est
il avait décidé de soigner coûte que
coûte
il est 23 heures et se fait maintenant
près trois semaines que le service est
impliqué dans l'impression charge de
patients infectés par le corps d'un
virus je veux dire c'est trois semaines
on les a pas vues passer dans leur
charge de travail est importante de jour
comme de nuit
bonjour jean philippe merci davance de
participer depuis votre place de chef de
service en réanimation avec les visites
désormais interdite aux familles
j'imagine que cela doit être dur j'ai
transgressé les règles du confinement
j'ai permis à des familles de venir même
si le patient allait bien mais parfois
ils avaient besoin de devoir c'est ses
parents sa famille
et puis on a autorisé des délais les uns
et les autres on a autorisé des visites
malgré les malgré les mesures mais on a
pris bien sûr les précautions
2 2 pour éviter tout tout tout risque de
transmission du virus
on peut pas imaginer je ne peux pas
imaginer qu'à car proche qui aime
quelqu'un depuis spa ne puisse pas le
voir cher mathieu comme on s'est dit je
vous invite à décrire le plus
concrètement possible ce qui se passe
dans votre service de psychiatrie alors
aujourd'hui c'est surtout la couleur on
est le 1er avril et ce n'était pas un
poisson d'avril
ce matin je reçois un mail du directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé
qui me dit qu'ils me félicite pour les
traits dans la gratitude barbara ce
qu'on a fait dans notre dévouement et c
est dans le même temps j'apprends mais
quasiment la même minute que les
réformes en cours contre l'hôpital
public ouvert à tous universel etc vont
se poursuivre et se renforcer
heureusement heureusement que on doit
faire face au quotidien pour nos
patients aujourd'hui j'ai une patiente
qui a été guérie du coc vide et trois
jours plus tard donc aujourd'hui ben lld
compan salle devient complètement excité
a été tout essoufflé tout pas bien et
on a pu quand même l'a transféré aux
urgences urgences débordées et puis on
s'est dit mais voilà est-ce que les
urgences ça risque pas de l'aggraver bon
voilà donc on a les remerciements d'un
côté le les couteaux dans le dos de
l'autre
et puis les gens qui ont besoin de nous
là dedans bien entendu mais heureusement
et elle s'est guéri du coc vide 72 ans
quand même pas mal écouté le monde
change et le nombre de décès est elle
hors d'ile-de-france qu'un hangar du
marché de rungis près paris va donc être
transformé en morgue
il s'agit de désengorger les services de
pompes funèbres qui sont eux aussi
saturé je les juges ont montré une
petite vidéo
quand je quitte mon service est mis au
service covin il est tard voilà l'état
du visage
je perçois bien mais c'est bien rouge
les marques marques de 12 heures 12
heures parce que comme on arrivait un
peu plus tôt le temps de se changer tout
ça et qu'on quitte ouais c'est plus de
dix heures voilà ainsi que les choux et
les choux les résultats des coiffes et
des calots aider charlotte
faut dire que je devrais ça me fait
plaisir d'être samaha théière du coucher
avec sept étoiles ce matin alors j'ai
pris des choses plus cool ça je sais pas
pourquoi le soir je suis très si je dors
mal et la nuit j'étais stressée étudient
ou alors à tanger sous payés depuis
trois ans je n'ai pas seront changées
avec que je vais tomber d'un toit était
le cerveau dont une petite pause café
quand même ça fait du bien et l'âge
attaque avec les toilettes
répondre aux sonnettes aussi vérifier
les sondes urinaires l'oxygène c'est
tout nouveau pour moi plus qu'avant
j'étais en ehpad donc c'est un bon
départ n'était pas à faire puis toute
façon faut que ça le fasse ça va le
faire on reste je reste forte je reste
prudente aussi et puis voilà je c'est là
que je travaille jusque lundi j'ai mardi
de repos et ensuite suspense je ne sais
toujours pas comment je vais bosser
après avoir
moi j'ai peur j'ai peur
donc heureusement je me dis mon hôpital
majeri il m'a fait l'épreuve on a vu
qu'on était capable
on peut faire en sorte d'accueillir les
patients prouver on est capable de gérer
cela mais le bordel nous rende vous
savez le bordel que c'est d'ouvrir un
service de fermer de transformer de
faire 6 1 de rouvrir un mois this ya
bien quelqu'un aussi qu'ils respectent
franchement respect si les cadres donc
ferme ce service on transforme en coller
est ce qu'on a le matériel et scandales
personnels
est-ce que c'est adapté est ce qu on a
tout ce qu'il faut et ce qu'on a ce
qu'il faut pour protéger notre personnel
est ce qu'on a ce qu'il faut pour
protéger nos soignants s mastiff ou pour
protéger nos malades est ce qu'on a le
médicament adapté est ce qu on a tout ça
est ce que tout ça mis en place vous
rendez compte
les nuits blanches qu'elles ont passées
à penser à tout ça alors je verrai
expliquer un peu tout je sais plus si je
les deals dans les vidéos mais du coup
j'étais en stage un fermier aubrac
élèves en première année et tout de
suite après j'ai fini le vendredi et le
samedi je suis tout de suite allé à
l'ehpad pour aider en tant qu'être et
soignante vacataires en fait en
discutant avec mes collègues que je me
suis rendu compte que il y avait eu un
cas positif pas dans mon secteur mais à
l'étagé du dessous et que le personnel
n'était pas informée des mesures
personne ne savait comment faire pour
gérer la situation
je me suis dit comment ça se fait que
dans un ehpad ça fait des mois qu'on en
parle que c'est les plus touchées où ses
plus virulents ça peut tuer le plus de
personnes
comment ça se fait que dans cet
établissement ils soient au courant de
rien bienvenue patrick dans notre équipe
oui bien sûr il faut témoigner de la
médecine de ville
merci d'avancé pour vos vidéos dans
votre région du grand ouest
la situation semble moins tendue c'est
samedi la garde a commencé depuis midi
jusqu'à minuit à près de minuit à 8
heures le samu prend le relais mais
demain dimanche je suis à la garde de 8
heures à minuit
aussi voilà donc j'étais super bien
accueillis par deux collègues
généralistes responsable du centre et on
a trinqué jus de gingembre curcuma c'est
bon pour la santé pour les défenses
immunitaires et puis y'a tout matériel
qu'il faut la voyez j'ai un masque ffp2
je l'enlève ce sera plus facile
bon ce soir je voulais vous parler de la
journée ça pas été une grosse journée
c'était très très calme j'ai eu que 4
patients une seule suspicion de kobe de
19 chez une femme qui n'êtes pas de
signe de gravité
et puis deuxième consultation à malade
d'un cancer métastasé
il ya 67 ans qui a une petite douleur
pas grand chose il avait tout ce qu'il
fallait en traitement et est en fait je
l'écouté je l'examiné on a discuté et
après ils étaient contents est reparti
chez lui et vous allez me dire ça sert à
quoi qu'il soit venu aux urgences un
dimanche la belle si justement ça sert à
ça ça aide d'urgence publique ça sert là
à écouter la douleur morale d'un type
qui va mourir dans pas longtemps
il le sait très bien et ça ça doit
servir à ça voilà on milite pour un
service public de la permanence de soins
24 heures sur 24
bonjour moins deux patients admis en
réanimation mais les chiffres restent
considérables la pression dans les
hôpitaux aussi témoignage d'une gériatre
au début de ce journal le confinement
seule solution à court terme prolonger
au delà du 15 avril c'est sûr jusqu à
cordes réponse d'emmanuel macron lundi
soir je rentre garder si vous voyez mais
c'est là alors aujourd'hui luxueux avec
des personnes âgées la plupart griesheim
heures et caen nice haimer on aime
beaucoup beaucoup marché se balader
partout il y avait
un patient il était énervé outré enfin
il comprenait pas pourquoi il n'avait
pas le droit de sortir du service etc
nous on a beau faire ce qu'on peut pour
l'empêcher d'aller dans les autres
services parce que les autres services
en fait ils sont contaminés ils sont
comment dire assez bloqué en fait pour
éviter la propagation du virus
et du coup c'était dur et même moi je me
sentais mal de lui interdire parce que
enfin faut le comprendre couaillier sais
pas il comprend pas tout bien il veut
interdire lui poser terek tout ça et
puis même se dire si lui il va se
baladent convoi peut ramener le laos
d'ailleurs une contaminer tous les
patients et ça ouais c'est un peu
compliqué et je commence à être très
fatigué parce qu'il ya moins de
personnel il faut faire plus attention
en fait du coup tout le monde et
confinés dans leur chambre donc repas
dans les chambres c'est plus dur
y a plus de règle et puis on est
toujours sous tension en fait
parce qu'il faut quoi faire quand même
on va devenir tout cela n'est qu'après
on sera tous bisous pasteur on sera un
beau défi buisson bogies sokolov
ben ouais tu aimerais tu les vois ils
ont tous un masque ouais alors va saluer
comme ça dans la vie
oui comme ça
[Musique]
en trait au plateau semble s'amorcer
selon la direction générale de la santé
le bilan des décès s'alourdit encore 5
154 morts de plus ces dernières 24
heures en hôpital 987 au total en
comptant les victimes en ehpad
[Musique]
oui oui il ne souffre pas il est sous
traitement sédatif tel que vous l'avez
vu cet après-midi traitement sédatif et
traitements contre contre la douleur les
profondément dormir
oui je crains qu'il ne décède euros au
cours de la nuit
je comprends
il n'est pas tout seul
nous sommes nous sommes avec lui même si
on peut plus rien pour lui
on n'abandonne pas ans occupe de lui je
comprends
si vous aussi vous souhaitez venir vous
venez à n'importe quel moment
oui oui bien sûr vous pouvez venir avec
vous pouvez venir avec vos enfants bien
sûr bien sûr je serai là je serai là je
vous remercie
c'est très gentil avant
bonsoir madame
ça va faire trois semaines là les gens
sont enfermés chez eux on a une
recrudescence de décompensation et là ce
qu'on voit c'est surtout des gens qui
sont mélancoliques
c'est à dire qu'ils ont une idée que la
lll aviez fini avec une catastrophe
d'effondrement des gens qui ont déjà eu
des vécus comme ça et qu'on va voir en
visite à domicile enfin la magie a été
plusieurs fois la semaine dernière voir
une dame qui avait l'impression que de
toute façon elle allait mourir est donc
bon autant mourir dans le silence et
seul alors une collègue a été à la
maison avec un autre collègue et puis
ils ont ils l'ont hospitalisé hier soir
et voilà on arrive au moment où notre
unité d'hospitalisation bas va être
saturé
je pense à toi vanessa la pression est
terrible et en plus tu entres dans un
nouveau service
toi qui a l'expérience à la fois de
l'ehpad et de l'hôpital peux tu parler
de tes conditions de travail et quand je
travaillais à l'ehpad pour le même
nombre d'heures je gagnais environ 1300
euros
et puis là l'hôpital d'environ 1600 et
j'arrive pas à comprendre puisque on
n'est pas le travail est très difficile
moi j'ai le souvenir de vas te faire
toilettes sur toile est de sans cesse de
m'occuper des gens à la chaîne pour les
oblige à se lever à telle heure à s'il
avait hâté leur à manger à telle heure
et puis l'égoutter sont toujours les
mêmes dans la fameuse madeleine celle ci
je n'en pouvais plus
j'ai l'impression de donner une ration
aux prisonniers puisque j'ai pas aimé
c'est d'arriver dans la chambre à 6h30
la réveiller la personne donc la lumière
en plein visage
le gant de toilette qui est prêt à
dégainer façon c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti après chaque soin c'est un
tamis de 20 minutes ça fait quand même
beaucoup
tu te rends compte j'ai encore trois
personnes derrière alors que la voile à
la fois là la personne pleurer elle
n'était pas bien période de confinement
elle voit pas sa famille il ya plus
d'animation reste voilà la personne
reste dans sa chambre et c'est très
frustrant de d'écouté 2 minutes et 10
rebonds à écouter martin schultz obligé
de vous laisser j'ai encore plein de
personnes derrière je suis désolé et ben
voilà donc on ferme la porte je ferme la
porte et je suis frustré je suis frustré
de ne pas pouvoir apporter plus d'être
que ça cette personne
[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes si je te mets à
m'adresser à vous ce soir après avoir
largement consulté ces derniers jours
c'est pour vous dire en toute
transparence ce qui nous attend pour les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
l'épidémie n'est pas encore maîtrisée
nous devons donc poursuivre nos efforts
et continuer d'appliquer les règles
c'est pour cela que le confinement le
plus strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai il nous faudra
nous rappeler aussi que notre pays
aujourd'hui tient tout entier sur des
femmes et des hommes que nous économie
reconnaissent ils rémunèrent si mal un
rabat ya des distinctions sociales ne
peuvent être fondées que sur l'utilité
commune
un multi niveaux ces mots des français
les ont écrits il ya plus de 200 ans
devons aujourd'hui reprendre le flambeau
et donner toute force à ce principe
je suis fatigué d'être qualifié de héros
comme beaucoup d'autres lorsqu'un eros
ça se tait sa réclame rien et puis
éventuellement sa mère ça me rend combat
moi j'ai pas envie de mater des tas de
choses à réclamer et puis j'ai pas envie
de mourir à cause de ce virus
je suis pas un jeu juste un médecin qui
a besoin de matériel qui a besoin de
médicaments cas besoin d'équipements
pour soigner ses patients pour soigner
nos concitoyens et j'en ai assez de ces
flagornerie je voudrais qu'il sait ce
qu'il nous donne ce dont on a besoin
[Musique]
donc on est mercredi 15 avril il me
semble c'est ça alors mâcon a fait la
locution lundi est en soi qu'est ce
qu'on apprend déconfinement à partir du
11 mai bien sûr on verra ce que ça donne
plus tard mise à part ça lors dans
l'établissement ils ont essayé de mettre
en place des tests pour le personnel
sauf que il ya juste une affiche était
écrit oui on réfléchit à si on va tous
vous faire dépister tout ça sauf que ça
fait une semaine unique c'est là qu'on
va pas d'autre information qui a rien
qui a été fait personne n'a été dépisté
donc c'est bien ce qu'ils font et tout
mais il ne m'aide pas encore en place en
fait chère marion
oui je suis très partante pour que vous
filmiez voter les consultations faites
le comme vous le souhaitez il suffit de
bien caler votre téléphone
l'important c'est de pouvoir vous
écouter oui dr thierry moungalla pareil
vous allez bien vous êtes toujours
confiné en lot-et-garonne l'alcool vous
êtes comment là du coup pendant ce
confinement comment vous gérez
vous consommez un peu plus ouais c'est
quoi que vous consommez vous d'accord
elles et à quel degré 7 degrés d'accord
vous prenez des 50 centilitres way est
ce que vous pouvez me décrire une
journée type avec l'alcool du coup là
pendant le confinement donc le plus tard
possible le matin
ouais café gâteaux et la bière arrive
combien de temps après du coup donc en
gros la vie la première bière et les
vers 9h quoi est ce que vous buvez d'une
manière différente
c'est un l'augmentation de la dose est
ce qu'elle est en lien avec une donc
c'est plutôt la l'ennui quoi nuit parce
que vous voyez personne
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous parler de
l'anxiété de l' angoisse n'a par exemple
une femme qui vient toujours avec son
gros sac à main avec plein de choses la
porte ou de sa ville jeunes chrétiens là
dedans et dé sa carte vitale son
chéquier c'est il faut d'autres familles
ces factures qui se trouve que
dernièrement la consultation était
tellement paniqués s'étaient de matin
qu' elle a tout fait tomber voilà tout
est parti par terre et puis elle avait
en même temps un papier kleenex dans une
poche en plastique
et puis elle apprenait alors par le
papier en guise de masque
mais prenez tout avec le plastique puis
elle essayait de se mettre ça moi je dis
attendez attendez on a des masques pour
vous et puis en tremblant et la réussit
quand même à mettre un masque en papier
qu'on lui avait fait confectionner
nous-mêmes évidemment cabine est en fait
le fait de s'asseoir broustet pour un
renouvellement de traitement
on se connaît maintenant un petit peu
depuis que plusieurs
moi que je la suis donc le lieu du
cabinet comme exutoire et comme comme un
dieu ou chou diverses son sac
au propre comme au figuré on déverse son
sac
si effectivement elle a tout fait tomber
par terre
voilà
je m'inquiète un peu cindy de n'avoir
rien reçu de toit depuis une semaine
comment ça va j'imagine que tu ne fais
que travailler loin de ton mari et de
tes enfants vient avant mon arrivée au
téléphone et puis j'ai eu mes enfants en
visio et j'ai vu ma ma cacahuètes ma
cadette ma petite princesse qui a cinq
ans je n'ai pas reconnu le visage très
pâle les yeux cernés elle qui est pleine
de frisettes ses cheveux tour être ai je
dit ça va pas cacahuètes à fait non
j'suis fatigué vraiment je la sentais
triste reste heureusement pas bien et
donc du coup après j'ai appris mon mari
je dis pas comment ça va au niveau avec
orianne et line dit ça va pas du tout
aller en allant des primes totales à 5
ans la petite mouche quasi plus elle
pleure beaucoup elle fait plutôt de
caprice j'ai dit que maman à la maison
nous manque donc c'est très difficile
même si l'élection papa son frère sa
soeur sa grand mère et son grand père
qu'elle voit régulièrement là
malheureusement le confinement lui fait
plus du mal est que de la protéger donc
encore une fois le bénéfice risque il
faut le calculer est donc bah tu étais
fait rentrer à la maison
mais voilà faudra que joue explique que
oui tu peux rentrer à la maison mais pas
de bisou à maman paquereau qu'à la maman
tu pourras voir maman où ils feront pas
trop se rapprocher pour les préserver
mais peut-être que ça lui fera du bien
là vos classeurs de cette déprime
soyez les bienvenus sur france inter
bonjour à tous nous sommes le mercredi
22 avril à diass soubiran bonjour le
retour dans les classes se précise mais
l'école à la maison concernera encore
beaucoup d'élèves passé le 11 mai après
l' angoisse du confinement l'angoissent
du déconfinement les psychiatres
s'inquiète chère vanessa s'occuper seule
de tes enfants
ça ne doit pas être simple en ce moment
tu t'en sors entre le travail et la
maison
bon alors c'est pas compliqué ligne tu
commences comment alors on va commencer
par la première opération
comment on va les voir deux fois trois
ça veut dire multipliez ça veut dire que
le chiffre tu vas le compté deux fois
d'accord donc deux fois 3 si bon bah
voilà ça y est ça revient une fois vite
vite c'est bien une fois 2-2 c'est bien
beau
alors aujourd'hui on a reçu les masques
de l'hôpital alors ce sont des masques
formidable ils prennent vraiment bien
toute la tête ce qui est très commode
pour pour se protéger intégralement pour
se voiler la face
mahdi un collègue facétieux bon alors
ils sont vraiment très très bien cousue
si on montre un peu c'est un peu
rock'n'roll c'est à dire que maintenant
l'hôpital public c'est serock il ya des
défilants plus c'est intéressant parce
que regarder
en fait si il ya le lay alco vide alors
en fait comme ça vous pouvez au fur et à
mesure enlever le coville la contacter
c'est un fils de covile on peut le
relever et ça protège tout cas si vous
voyez ça permet de ne pas avoir des
projections sur les dans les yeux avec
les d'armes
c'est pas mal c'est mathieu bellahsen en
direct de son basque intérieur manon
médecins pareils
wahou mathieu c'est dingue on se demande
vraiment s'il faut en rire ou en pleurer
heureusement que ces masques vous sont
fournis pour la vie en dehors du travail
pas pour l'hôpital il fallait travailler
le matin normal avec toujours cette
douleur qui partait pas dans la matinée
je me sentais vraiment pas bien avec
perte de force fatigue et du coup j'en
ai parlé à mes collègues et à ma cadres
et ils m'ont dit de rentrer chez moi de
prendre rendez vous avec un médecin
je suis un peu saoulé pense à ça tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps et
c'est dû au fort c'est vrai qu'on ne
pense qu'à ça mais c'est sans doute le
stress et ça se voit que tu es surmené
repose toi bien sûr tous et à très
bientôt
bonjour marion je suis d'accord il ne
faut pas négliger les dommages
collatéraux du confinement
tu aurais une autre consultation à me
montrer
oui bonjour vous allez bien ouais ça va
comment vous vivez en confinement
les consuls ça se passe comment on va
vous en êtes où par rapport à ça mais on
n'a pas trop vous arrivez à tenir la
cocaïne ça se passe comme
avec vos 110 milligrammes de méthane à
ça va là comme les opiacés allemand quoi
ça commence à vous gonflez de quoi ne
pas voir aussi ouais là vous avez
toujours des skype avec n elle veut pas
vous parler c'est sûr que vers 3 ans
c'est un peu compliqué d'expliquer tout
ça et le fait que vous puissiez pas la
voir et tout ça et la famille d'accueil
comment ça se passe avec elle de vous
savez et vous vous auriez l'occasion
d'envoyer des choses à votre fille j'ai
pas des photos des dessins des lettres
d'essayer de trouver des moyens pour
pour alimenter votre relation un petit
mot à toute l'équipe
comment ça va à dix jours du 10
confinement je sais que pour vous ce ne
sera pas la libération
bien au contraire alors je voulais
profiter d'avoir en quart d'heure on va
dire en gros la junte finir 1 7 heures
de travail à l'hôpital mots servent
voilà service du matin et là je repars
tout de suite à la boulangerie pour
l'aider pour faire vendeuse à la
boulangerie
donc j'ai eu le temps de manger ça va
mais c'est vrai que enchaîné avec les
des bleus c'est un peu dur
[Applaudissements]
bon le service est calme ce matin c'est
c'est ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
depuis tout séjour ou où tout était
assez agitée assez intense là on a
peut-être une journée devant nous on va
pouvoir souffler un petit peu mais ça
fait du bien ça fait du bien parce
bazdar du sommet de loulou que coco on a
de la chance d'avoir un petit jardin ils
peuvent être dehors c'est chouette
oui c'est bien ma chérie j'ai tellement
peur en tant que maman de la faire
remettre à l'école parce que c'est ce
qu'elle veut je dis attention il faudra
bien respectée si ça parce que j'ai peur
moi aussi j'ai peur pour mon enfance
j'ai peur pour mon mari j'ai peur pour
eux pour toute ma famille et je lui ai
dit attention parce que tu risques le
ramener à la maison tout ça est ce que
c'est moi qui ai créé ce psychose
possible c'est tout à fait possible
je dis pas que je suis pas je suis
parfaitement non non je suis je fais des
erreurs comme tout le monde et je me dis
c'était peut-être que sceptiques aux
niveaux du virus je lui ai transmis mais
en même temps je me dis peut-être qu'il
faut qu'elle ait un peu peur de ce virus
parce que celle ci permettra de qu'elle
prenne conscience que c'est important
les gestes derrière les choses comme ça
à 5 ans c'est normal qu'un enfant il
perd mourir nommant à 5 ans un enfant ça
devait être insouciants ça doit jouer ça
doit s'amuser ça doit pas avoir de plan
en en train de créer des traumatismes à
nos enfants et moi j'en créant aussi à
ma fille parce qu intérieurement avec
tout ce que je lui dis les protections
qu'il faut qu'elle fasse cette psychose
s'est bêtement aussi qu'il est
[Musique]
je regarde en arrière
je vous vois et je vais
je vous revois
même le
je m'ouvre
je regarde
je vous
sur la route
tout en bas robin
même quand des noix je vous
j'avoue trop
1000mercis vanessa ça fait un bien fou
il faut trouver des moyens de continuer
à vivre de penser à autre chose
insomnie bonsoir encore une fois voilà à
changer intérieur de nuit ces comprimés
collector donc là ça y est on est le 11
mai il est exactement 2h56 déconfinement
[Musique]
professionnellement commencé et j'ai
peur que les gens se lâchent
cela j'ai finalement 6 aurore chez pas
de symptômes oh allez on y va on bat pas
la théorie un recueil est un copain et
les copains elle est exposée fait beau
un pique nique a mené on fait aller
super on craint de confinement et puis
on pioche choses en un paquet chez qui
on prend tous la bouteille à la main et
compte en france mais tous les yeux et
si c'est toutes petites choses
ils font que la continue la
contamination va se poursuivre et la
deuxième à paris et j'ai peur qu'elle
arrive n'est plus violente que la
première j'espère me tromper
j'espère de tout coeur on peut pas
savoir l'audience mais bonjour à tous
avec de l'actualité ce matin c'est le
jour j du thé confinement après 55 jours
à l'art et la vie économique reprend
doucement et différemment masque
obligatoire dans les transports gestes
barrières notre vie a changé
aujourd'hui ça a été une journée intense
puisque son ca a commencé ce matin par
le fait que je découvre que tous les
patients qui entrait à l'hôpital et est
enfermé à clé pendant 72 heures
du coup j'ai contacté le procureur de là
public j'ai fait un courrier en disant
qu' il y avait un potentiel
séquestration au sens du code pénal et
tout ça sous prétexte sanitaires c'est à
dire que enfermer quelqu'un à clé serait
légitime et par son état infectieux il
soit qu'ovide qu'ils soient prêts covin
avoue que j'ai pas trop le moral
voilà ma fille reprend l'école doit vous
au plus haut niveau des devoirs donc je
stresse un peu pour elle quand elle va
arriver à l'école parce qu'à la fin
j'avoue que je carrément laissé tomber
trop fatigué pour assumer les cours les
douars me battre avec ça
oui voilà
voilà je suis rentré du travail la peine
et voilà ce que je retrouve donc des
enfants qui m'aident plus du tout je
rentre et je dois tout me taper et il ya
de quoi vraiment pété les plombs
j'en ai marre ils ont mangé kebab ça
traîne par terre normal on va passer du
tout les pompes
j'en peux plus c'est vraiment une
journée où j'en peux plus où j'ai
vraiment envie de péter les plombs parce
que je n'ai du soutien de personne je
prends soin de tout le monde dans mon
travail à l'extérieur et je me rends
compte que tu vas y a personne qui prend
soin de moi quoi personne personne
personne peut dire que je suis
absolument sous terre que le moment
qu'on a traversé en fait se concrétise
par part encore plus de destructions que
les gens vont très mal que on a plus de
dix personnes hospitalisées en plus de
ce qu'on peut accueillir voilà que
le lien entre les gens se détériorent
eux oui bonjour c'est le docteur tirer
ming
oui bonjour vous allez bien ouais bon
comment vous avez vécu ce confinement
et oui du coup au niveau de la sexualité
ça a été compliqué le confinement
j'imagine d'accord l'ailier de rencontre
ont tous été fermés et vous n'avez pas
pu en fait avoir accès ce que je vous
propose du coup si vous pensez commencé
à faire on va l'appeler comme ça votre
déconfinement sexuelle plus tôt en juin
essayez dans un premier temps de pas
forcément avoir de multiples partenaires
que vous connaissez pas trop et tout ça
et avoir le partenaire dont vous parlez
là qu'est un peu stable peut-être voir
avec lui si c'est un peu confiné et
convenablement et qu'il n'ya pas il n'a
pas trop de symptomatologie que voilà et
puis bah oui c'est quand même incroyable
on sait se protéger du vih mais voilà
trente ans que je me bats je reconnais
des choses intéressantes
[Musique]
à noël
confirme en france mais plus qu'on dit
plus de charlotte du confinement
donc du coup alors des entretiens un
suspect cofide pour mes chemises de nuit
séné patients dont une située 12 en
plastique
bon après le nez lunettes épine us sp2
quoi mais nous lançons aujourd'hui le
secteur de la santé avec deux
convictions simple d'abord nous vivons
des temps exceptionnels et ensuite on ne
répondra pas à la crise que nous
connaissons par des demi-mesures et par
des choix rapide et assumer alors le
secteur de la santé ils nous demandent
qu'est ce qui a bien fonctionné pendant
la crise je n'ai rien sauf l'auto
réorganisation de notre cabinet médical
plus d'autonomie whip meilleure
rémunération bah oui on peut être que
d'accord plus d'écouté de prise en
compte des suggestions bah oui c'est un
peu des portes dès qu'on défonce des
portes ouvertes un plus au travail en
équipe
ouais voilà à mais fallait cocher une
seule bon alors selon vous quelles
devraient être les investissements
prioritaires pour améliorer le
fonctionnement du système de santé
investissements dans le lot pital public
donc l'hôpital public
interdiction du privé à but lucratif et
donc le silure de la santé va rendre ses
conclusions en juillet mais ça s'est il
va y avoir encore des mesures qui vont
qu'ils vont passer dans notre dos quoi
c'est ça le problème c'est que les
j'espère qu'on sera assez vigilant pour
pour réagir à ça donc je donne rendez
vous à tous les soignants le 16 juin
déjà pour la grosse manifestation qui a
dans toutes les villes en france pour
défendre des salaires des soignants et
les conditions de travail
voilà chers cindy je sais que tu avais
quelques jours de congé tellement
nécessaire j'espère que tu as pu
recharger un peu tes batterie avec ta
famille je te souhaite plein de courage
hop
ce soir je fais une vidéo depuis mon
service je travaille c'est le service
que j'avais quitté juste avant d'être en
vacances et les jours de ça et là quel
plaisir quel plaisir de rentrer et de
retrouver donc c'est un service
gériatrique coville est de retrouver là
une grande grande grande partie de mes
patients qu'ovide les boîtes qui pètent
la forme qu'ils ont bien récupéré
je les ai quittés était à plus de 6
litres d'oxygène
et puis voilà ils vont tous supérieurs
j'ai passé l'année ennuis depuis qu'on
en profite on a deux quasi centenaire
bondi plus forte qu'elle convient donc
une que je connaissais depuis un petit
moment parce que je m'en suis occupé ça
faisait un petit moment qu'elle était
déjà chez nous qui est en rééducation et
qu'on a gardé plus longtemps qu'ils
attrapent hilco vide mais j'avais
tellement peur pour elle et elle l'a
battue et je lui dis je dis bah alors on
passe à la télé on devient une star elle
me dit que je suis passe à la télé jd
oui j'ai dit vous savez pas ce que vous
avez battu le virus et vous savez ce
qu'il m'a dit comme quoi moi j'adore la
gériatrie pour ça elle m'a dit eva si ça
peut motiver les gens à se battre et à
pas spécial et par ce virus
eh ben je suis fier de moi et moi je lui
ai dit vous savez quoi
vous avez raison vous pouvez très très
fier de vous parce que honnêtement vous
leur avez montré que qu importe l'âge il
faut y croire et il faut se battre et
anna monde et ça ça vaut tous les
applaudissements savons toutes les
reconnaissances du monde
ces personnes là c'est eux qui nous
donne vraiment du baume au coeur qui
nous donne envie de nous battre
que passe on se dit même si c'est dur
physiquement même si c'est au niveau du
salaire on est non
mais payer mais une misère par rapport à
d'autres pays même si c'est épuisant et
tout ça quand on a la reconnaissance de
nos nos passions à ce moment là bas on
se dit merde ça ça nous fait du
bien et ça me motive à continuer à se
battre dans notre métier et c'est ça qui
nous donne cette petite femme qui nous
fait tenir et nous dit qu'on continue je
m'excuse faut qu'on continue à se battre
pour qu'on continue pour eux parce que
ils ont besoin de nous et la
reconnaissance le remerciement qui nous
donne derrière basse et ça c'est notre
c'est notre carburant principal c'est ce
qui nous motive
bon voilà c'est une petite vidéo comme
ça pour vous dire c'était j'ai passé une
nuit extra mais qu'est ce que ça
fait du bien ça fait énormément delà
elle est bonne je salue mathieu ou en
étude ton combat contre la séquestration
de des patients à l'hôpital
je repense à ta colère de voir fermer
les portes
alors que toi et tes équipes vous
travaillez depuis des années à faire
reculer l'enfermement des gens en
psychiatrie c'était un grand week-end
avec un feriel c'est un l'on pense ce
week-end mais j'ai dû aller quand même à
l'hôpital parce qu'on aurait accueilli
tous nos patients qui étaient confinés
la suite pour le contrôleur des libertés
basse et qu'une note a été publié nous
donnons gagnent cause quoi c'est à dire
que les patients qui sont en
hospitalisation libre ont pas est
enfermé
mansaly père isolant psychiatrique voilà
au milieu de tout ça bon ben c'est quand
même les patients qui trinquent
le journal bonjour sparaco lauzon jours
nicolas bonjour a tous un jour par
semaine en visioconférence le ségur de
la santé lancé il ya quinze jours
avancent lentement les soignants
attendant toujours du concret je paie
très révolté d'habitude mais là je suis
un peu dégoûté quand même parce que ben
aujourd'hui mes collègues ont reçu la
prime qu'ovide et moi j'ai pas droit
j'ai pas droit pourquoi parce que ben
j'ai travaillé en ehpad avant d'arriver
à l'hôpital pendant le confinement et
j'étais à 30 heures semaine et donc
l'hôpital donc viens de le dire que en
fait pour que je bénéficie de cette
prime il y aurait fallu que je sois à 35
heures donc voilà
nous n'avons pas à rougir mes chers
compatriotes de notre bilan
les dizaines de milliers de vies ont été
sauvées dans nos choix
par nos actions d'oublier quelques jours
nos capacités de réanimation organiser
des transferts de centaines de patients
entre régions et avec les pays voisins a
provisionné au commerce réorienter notre
propre
son industriel inventé les nouvelles
solidarités la période a montré que nous
avons du ressort de la région sera
facile ce qui nous a frappés
donc nous sommes le 7 juin
aujourd'hui c'est la panique donc j'ai
mis pour pour sortir le beau masque
fournies par l'hôpital
il ya toujours les fils kobe d'ardisson
là vous permettre de taxes et donc et
donc on va parce que c'est clair
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutez le monde change et c'est un peu
moins que ce qu'ils espéraient mais
c'est un peu plus que ce que proposait
le gouvernement au départ un accord a
finalement été trouvé dans le secteur de
la santé 180 euros net par mois en plus
pour tous les personnels soignants
hospitalier est les syndicats exigeaient
jusqu'ici une hausse de 300 euros mais
il accepte donc ce compromis après une
ultime nuit de négociations c'est pas
très satisfaisant qu'on a vraiment
l'impression de travailler pour rien et
voilà mais si y'a pas de bras en plus je
vois pas ce que ça changera au quotidien
la fatigue sera toujours la langue de
personnel sera toujours là les arrêts
vont continuer parce que les sonnets
n'en peuvent plus donc c'est des arrêts
sont la fatigue fait que ça ne s'arrête
ce que les essonniens n'en peuvent plus
qu'on est vraiment une très fatigué son
prix juillet et dure non négligeable de
reprise de l'économie
on l'apprenait non plus tard le virus
circule toujours
et les vagues se succèdent plus de 90000
personnes ont perdu la vie
une grande campagne de vaccination est
en cours
tana et a réussi ses examens
elle est passée en 2e année pour elles à
prendre en pleine épidémie
c'est devenu son quotidien mais beaucoup
d'étudiants de son école ont renoncé en
fin de première année
dana et découvre à quel point elle
s'attache aux patients âgés même si
c'est beaucoup plus dur que ce qu'elle
imaginait surtout ces derniers mois elle
se dit qu'elle vit un moment historique
et ali mais toutes ses forces
patrick à trouver un médecin pour lui
succéder au cabinet pour pouvoir
s'engager dans la médecine du travail et
aider à prévenir les atteintes à la
santé des travailleurs
il se dit usé physiquement et
psychiquement
mais toujours viscéralement attachés aux
soins et à la préservation de la santé
pour lui cela veut dire avant tout
écouter et chercher à diminuer la
souffrance des personnes toutes les
personnes
vanessa a dû quitter l'hôpital de
remiremont à l'automne 2020 victime d'un
syndrome de burn out
après quatre mois d'arrêt elle a intégré
un nouvel ehpad dans sa région des
vosges c'est un établissement où les
résidents sont respectés et traités
dignement où elle ne ressent plus que
celle usines selon sa propre expression
mathieu est toujours en colère contre
les dysfonctionnements du système de
santé contre la bureaucratie et
l'évident manque de moyens depuis la
première vague
lui et son équipe ont été confrontés
chaque jour à la souffrance des
personnes accueillies en psychiatrie qui
subissent une double peine
le confinement physique qui redouble
isolement psychique
il milite toujours en tentant de
concilier le temps pour la lutte pour
ces patients et pour sa famille jean
philippe a été vaccinée fin janvier 2021
ce qui l'a rassuré mais aussi rassurer
ses proches son centre hospitalier à
dieppe souffre de l'absence de nombreux
soignants atteint du coc vide ou tout
simplement épuisé
même si la situation reste très
préoccupante
il est confiant car son service de
réanimation poursuit sa mission grâce à
l'investissement sans faille de ses
médecins et de ses équipes auprès des
patients marion a décidé de quitter la
ville d'agen pour proposer des
consultations dans les zones
désertifiées du lot et garonne
cela lui permettra d'être au plus près
des personnes dont cette crise
interminable aggrave la précarité et
l'isolément notamment psychique
marion a d'ailleurs décidé de se former
en psychiatrie cindy est toujours
infirmière à l'hôpital edouard herriot
de lyon est là le projet de devenir
cadre de santé pour avoir davantage de
responsabilités et ainsi apporter son
énergie aux équipes actuellement cindy
reste dans ce qu'on appelle le pool
c'est à dire qu'elle n'est pas rattachée
à un service en particulier mais depuis
le début de l'épidémie s'étend service
qu'ovide qu'elle passe toutes ses nuits
[Musique]
je regarde en arrière
je vous vois les yeux vers la terre je
vous revois
même le
je vous rends
je regarde
je vous
sur la route
tout en va de robin de là
je vous
même quand
moi je vous
vva
balala
là
[Musique]
en